alors j'aurais pu vous parler
exclusivement des résultats de mes
recherches
mais aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de sortir
un peu de ma zone de confort et de vous
parler de choses un peu plus un peu plus
intime d'une histoire personnelle
d'expériences personnelles qui me sont
arrivées dans l'espoir en fait que cela
puisse éveiller en vous je tirais notre
vision du monde
si je suis là aussi et bien c'est pour
honorer une promesse que j'ai faite en
grandes sommes pas n'importe laquelle la
personne la plus inspirante que j'ai
l'occasion de deux rencontres et en fait
dans cette vie un puisqu'il s'agit de ma
maman quand on peut voir sur cette photo
alors lorsque j'étais haute comme trois
pommes à l'âge de 8 ans dans les années
80 la science la médecine moderne à
détecter une tumeur incurable au niveau
de cerveau de maman je comprenais pas
très bien ce que ça voulait dire tu
meurs à 8 ans vous rencontrez vous
pouvez bien imaginer ça mais cependant
j'ai vite compris que la situation était
extrêmement grave lorsque les médecins
ont précisé qu'il lui restait que trois
mois trois petits mois à vivre
alors je me rappelle à l'époque on avait
l'habitude les mercredis après-midi
d'aller à lui met une petite bougie avec
maman allumez bouger et faire quelques
prières dans l'une ou l'autre église
maman expliqué qu'elle avait la foi
alors la fois pour moi c'était plutôt
subtile impalpable moi il était hors de
question en fait que je m'adresse à un
dieu une intelligence soi-disant
bienveillante et supérieur qui rendait
tout simplement ma maman malade alors
force est de reconnaître que j'ai dû
réévaluer ma position
en observant simplement avec quelle
force et qu'elle fois ma maman a
combattu en fait cette grave maladie
et puis surtout comment laguérie comment
elle a guéri qu'on entre les je dirais
quand toutes les attentes contre tous
les pronostics et tous les avis médicaux
des personnes et des médecins que nous
avions consulté à l'époque
alors bien sûr elle a fait l'objet de
nombreuses batteries d'examens
complémentaires au chu ici à liège pour
essayer de comprendre d'où provenait
cette rémission totale complète et
totalement inexpliquée pour maman
c'était très simple sa guérison était dû
à sa foi profonde mais aussi assez
différente prière méditative quotidienne
qu'elle faisait alors évidemment ces
tranches de vie a profondément influencé
mon cheminement professionnel puisque
après un doctorat en biomédical dans le
domaine de l'oncologie cancérologie ici
à liège eh bien j'ai obtenu comme
grégory vlady différents différents
diplômes patrie le diplôme qui me
permettait de pouvoir gérer et
coordonner de très gros projets de
recherche toujours dans le domaine de
l'oncologie cancérologie projets de
recherche entre universités et
entreprises
donc encore une fois le jeu mettait
toute ma force et mon savoir à combattre
ce cancer cette maladie terrible qui
nous touche tous en fait de près ou de
loin est malheureusement souvent de bien
trop près
bien malheureusement malgré tout toute
cette connaissance accumulée trente ans
après la rémission son premier cancer je
devais personnellement annoncé à ma
maman
la présence d'une tumeur importante au
niveau du poumon tumeurs dites terminal
envoie terminal puisque les métastases
touché d un déjà les différents aux
différentes parties osseuse de de son
corps et de la colonne vertébrale
alors je dois bien avouer que cette
accumulation d'erreurs médicales et de
diagnostic qui a duré plus d'un an a
engendré une douleur atroce au niveau
physique mais aussi émotionnel et
psychique du à 7 à cette nouvelle bien
sûr et à la présence de ce cancer une
semaine après je démissionnais de toutes
mes responsabilités professionnelles
pour pouvoir l'accompagner sur sur son
chemin l'accompagner dans son combat a
commencé alors notre chemin initiatique
alors c'est vraiment dans ce désespoir
dans ce désarroi dans ce que j'appelle
la nuit noire de l'âme en fait que j'ai
vécu ce qu'on appelle une expérience
énergétique spontanée alors je suis sûr
que très peu de personnes savent de quoi
je parle je ne vais pas vraiment
expliqué tout en détail mais simplement
vous expliquer que cette expérience
puissante d'une puissance inouïe en
faite consistait en un flux énergétiques
qui m'a traversé le corps spontanément
littéralement de la tête aux pieds pieds
à la tête pendant un certain temps
alors moi j'étais complètement
déconnecté de la réalité à ce moment là
donc je ne sais pas combien de temps ça
dure et peut-être peut-être une heure
pendant ce temps j'étais complètement
pétrifié liquéfié en essayant
désespérément de trouver des points de
repère dans le connu c'est à dire dans
le domaine scientifique
mais force était dé reconnaître que que
je n'arrivais pas à trouver un ses
points de repères et que lorsque
l'expérience est atténuée et bien
c'était important pour moi de comprendre
ce qui s'était passé je n'arrivais pas à
mme apaisé évidemment donc j'ai commencé
à essayer de comprendre de manière
cartésienne structure et scientifique
voire physiologique à ce qui s'était
passé au niveau de mon corps
alors dans un premier temps j'ai fait le
lien avec certaines traditions
ancestrales
certaines pratiques que vous connaissez
peut-être comme le tai-chi le klingon
mais également le yoga qui apprend à
maîtriser en fait cette énergie ces flux
d'énergie
évidemment j'ai fait aussi le lien avec
la pathologie de maman et tout ce qui
comptait pour moi à ce moment là c'était
de découvrir comment maîtriser ses
énergies cette force que j'avais en moi
depuis cette expérience est en fait une
voie complètement inexploré par la
médecine traditionnelle occidentale
médecine dite moderne
alors je me suis plongée évidemment dans
ce que je connaissais c'est à dire les
bouquins de physique quantique avec un
max planck avec nikola tesla mais aucun
de parler de cette énergie ou qu'en
parler de ce qui s'était nager de vie
jusqu'à ce que mes recherches et la vie
en fait tu me fasses rencontre et nassim
ram est in qui en fait considéré comme
le n stand du troisième millénaire
enfin un génie physicien cave un visage
sympathique et bienveillant alors en
fait qui est extraordinaire et nassim
c'est que il démontre scientifiquement
implication internationale que tout et
énergie tout le physique mais également
les émotions les pensées entre vous et
moi vous pensez que c'est du vide mais
en fait c'est bourré massacre d'énergie
d'accord au delà c'est nassim fait le
lien avec les traditions ancestrales
avec tes sagesse ancestrale et surtout
ceux qui cette énergie de vie alors
autant vous dire qu'après tout ce
parcours de recherche touché ce poids de
conscience est prise de conscience doit
donner en effet un peu comme ça la voyez
le truc vraiment dans le corps ce cri de
victoire d'avoir compris certaines
choses et puis comme je sais qu'on est à
liège et qui a certainement quelques
valeureux liégeois parmi nous et bien ça
donnait ça aussi le cri de victoire de
steve myler je comptais pas m'arrêter là
évidemment parce que c'est intéressant
de savoir que tout et énergie déjà c'est
rassurant par rapport à l'expérience que
j'ai vécue
encore fallait-il pouvoir expliquer
comment comment ça fonctionne massim
avait fait le lien avec des traditions
ancestrales et c'est donc la voie que
j'ai suivi pour essayer de comprendre
voir si ces enseignements
nous laisser des codes des clés en fait
de compréhension comment maîtriser cette
énergie et donc je me suis renseigné
j'ai cherché au niveau des spiritualités
des sagesse ancestrale et j'ai fait le
lien avec regarder sur ces images les
orioles 1
ce qu'on appelle aussi les aura dans la
spiritualité indépendamment de tout
discours religieux essayer de tout dogme
la spiritualité ou en tous les cas cette
vestiges d'un temps passé nous montrer
quelque chose s'il y avait une voie là
alors il faut savoir que ce champ
électromagnétique ou aura est à présent
détectable la science a eu aussi ces dix
dernières années une ouverture de
conscience et elle a mis au point au
niveau de différents instituts et
universités de projets de recherche que
je suis de très près avec lesquels je
collabore ce qu'on appelle des électro
photo m c'est à dire des appareils de
mesures qui permettent de mesurer mais
même bien au delà d'analyser ces photons
électromagnétiques donc c'est cette
lumière en fait que nous dégageons c'est
énergie que nous dégageons constamment
et donc oui concrètement nous sommes ce
qu'on appelle des êtres lumineux
d'accord alors je voulais pas m'arrêter
en si bon chemin
je voulais un petit peu voir ce qu'on
pouvait encore trouver au niveau de sa
sagesse ancestrale et donc comme vous le
voyez sur cette statuette en pierre
eh bien on montre ici le coeur comme
étant une voie royale en fait à l'être
tu es d'accord
ici on voit notamment ce qu'on appelle
le sacré peur donc en fait ce lien avec
le choeur est clairement démontré dans
les sagesse ancestrale la spiritualité
comme étant en fait une clé de
connaissance une clé de sagesse inverse
une autre dimension de l'être du bien
être et de l'évolution de l'être humain
alors il s'est encore même si la science
n'a rien inventé elle valide manar elle
valide par des technologies de plus en
plus fine ce que les connaissances ce
que les anciens connaissaient déjà très
bien
alors qu'est ce qu'a démontré sans
concurrent ça démontre que le champ
électromagnétique du coeur et cinq mille
fois supérieur cinq mille fois supérieur
aux champs électromagnétiques du cerveau
énorme et que quand on utilise ces
approches thérapeutiques énergétique
dont je vais parler
eh bien on arrive à entrer en cohérence
ses différents systèmes physiologiques
du corps entrent en cohérence que soit
le système nerveux central périphériques
sympathique parasympathique peu importe
système hormonal
donc il ya un réel effet de cohérence
cardiaque qui s'installe avec tous les
bienfaits que l'on peut imaginer au
niveau notamment de la gestion du stress
la gestion de cette tension que l'on
peut ressentir au quotidien entre autres
choses
j'ai donc parcouru le monde pour essayer
de me former
apprendre à maîtriser en fait ces
différents flux énergétiques et pouvoir
les proposer à des fins thérapeutiques
aussi fait l'acquisition d'un électro
photo m et sur cette photo on voit un
exemple parmi tant d'autres dans adultes
avant le soin à gauche après un soin à
droite second voit le champ
électromagnétique avec les différentes
pathologies que l'on pouvait observer
avant comme des trous ou des noeuds qui
sont littéralement harmoniser la
personne sort boost en énergie avec un
impact clair au niveau du stress comme
on peut le voir en orange niveau de
stress de la personne avant le soin et
en bleu indigo après le soin le cas
également d'un enfant ici avec plusieurs
pathologies comportementale on voit
avant le soin restauration du champ
électromagnétique
après le soin alors le champ
électromagnétique qui s'est mesurée avec
cette aura bleus mais chaque organe
chaque système est mesurée avec cet
appareil avec un effet drastiques au
niveau de la gestion du stress avant
après soins orange avant le soin bleus
après le soin alors évidemment ces
différentes thérapies ont pas mal de
bénéfices qui sont démontrés je les dis
au niveau du système immunitaire au
niveau de la gestion du mental gestion
émotionnelle également le calme la
possibilité de gérer certaines douleurs
qu'elle soit physique émotionnel ou
psychique
alors sur ce parcours j'ai rencontré
beaucoup de beaucoup difficulté je dois
bien vous l'avouer
dans un premier temps un difficultés
d'ordre personnel
essayez d'accepter cette expérience m'a
fallu un an pour en parler même à mon
mari
imaginez en vrai c'est de comprendre ce
qui s'était passé apprendre à gérer ces
flux apprendre à faire confiance à mes
ressentis personnel
la deuxième difficulté que j'ai dû
affronter c'est lorsque j'ai voulu me
positionner en tant que thérapeute à un
thérapeute en énergie ou là j'étais
vraiment confrontés à des préjugés
énorme au niveau de la société
alors effectivement quel gâchis avec de
si beaux diplômes doctorat un billet
toute sorte de diplôme je dirais
extrêmement cartésien factuel concret
valorisé par la société aussi
financièrement bien sûr et la troisième
difficulté était de pouvoir valider
scientifiquement de prouver quelque part
ce qui s'était passé ce en quoi j'ai cru
alors aujourd'hui vous n'êtes peut-être
pas au courant mais c'est en quoi
j'écris est validée par la séance je les
montre et mais ces thérapies sont aussi
en fait pratiquer dans de nombreux
hôpitaux en europe mais également aux
usa et même remboursé par certaines
mutuelles
vous voyez que les esprits les préjugés
éclate en fait face aux résultats
obtenus et en belgique ma foi on
commence progressivement à ouvrir aussi
notre champ de conscience donc en dise
je dirais deux premières conclusions à
ce chemin ce parcours de vie je dirais
ceci c'est de toujours toujours avoir
confiance dans vos ressentis et de vous
rendre compte que l'élan l'élan du coeur
d'énergie du coeur extrêmement puissante
si vous avez des décisions à prendre
quelque part entre les clans ce qui
concerne la direction de votre vie peu
importe où vous en êtes peu importe vos
diplômes je vous inviterai vraiment plus
à man à vous faire confiance
toujours
alors j'avais envie moi de vous faire
des petites les petits cadeaux vous
offrir des petites pépites des petites
clés des petites clés de conscience des
clés de sagesse que vous allez peut-être
pouvoir utiliser directement
développement personnel dans votre
quotidien ou en développement
énergétique et peut-être même être
transformé par ses prises de conscience
alors la première concerne ici une
expérience qui est réalisée par
l'université de princeton
quelle est cette première qui est
conscient c'est bien cette vous rendre
compte que chacun d'entre nous ici
présent est capable de créer mais
également de diriger et de gérer des
flux énergétiques de manière spontanée
et naturelle de manière innée note
d'ailleurs ces flux à votre insu sont
calculées et analysés depuis un peu plus
de dix ans par ce projet dont je parle
ici coordonnée par l'université de
princeton qui mesure de manière globale
au niveau de 40 laboratoires partout
dans le monde
mesures en faites quoi bien le niveau
d'énergie globale au niveau du champ
électromagnétique global alors comment
est-ce que ça se passe en clair chacun
d'entre vous est capable en posant votre
attention sur un objet ou sur un
événement est capable de générer un flux
énergétiques et donc au niveau collectif
au niveau mondial et bien c'est cette
expérience mesure des choses
extraordinaires
alors qu'est-ce qu'elle mesure voici par
exemple un exemple qui correspond aux
attaques du 11 septembre
vous voyez un pic assez impressionnant
statistiquement probants en tous les cas
qu'il ya un pic de conscience collective
un pic de champs électromagnétiques
collectif lorsque chacun d'entre nous a
pris conscience en fait à de cet
événement et bien vous allez poser votre
regard vous déposez votre conscience
votre attention sur cet événement et
c'est démesuré
d'accord on voit un pic de toutes ces
énergies de tous ces flux
électromagnétiques que vous avez
envoyées de manière inconsciente
alors il ya beaucoup d'autres exemples
ici jeunes ainsi que quelques-uns de
tsunami en asie du sud en 2004 la visite
du pape en 2000 en terre sainte mais
également lorsque barack obama a gagné
les élections en 2008 beaucoup d'autres
en fait un laboratoire de recherche
utilisent cette technologie entre
guillemets des flux énergétiques comme
par exemple et si le professeur kawaii
qui lui en fait mesure le flux
électromagnétiques
au niveau tactique qu'est ce qu'il fait
en fait en visualisant en gérant ses
flux et bien vous gérer une pression
alors ce sera utilisée d'ici quelques
années en domotique
vous serez capable d'allumer par exemple
votre votre télévision ou d'autres
appareils électroniques et
électroménagers pardon à partir en fait
de cette technologie alors au niveau de
la méditation partout dans le monde
en fait on utilise déjà en fait cette
connaissance ancestrale
donc vous l'avez bien compris en quoi
est-ce que consiste la gestion des flux
donc vous posez votre esprit votre
attention dans le moment présent
un première condition et puis vous
l'avez compris si en plus vous tournez
votre regard de l'extérieur vers
l'intérieur et bien vous vous remplissez
d'énergie vous ressourcer littéralement
alors ces approches évidemment sont
grandement utilisé également dans les
entreprises pour la gestion un montage
et son notionnels le stress mais
également les les burnout et si google
est un très bon exemple
alors la dernière petite pépite le
dernier petit cadeau ici encore une fois
offert par les enseignements des
traditions et sagesse ancestrale c'est
la voie en fait du milieu où la voix du
centre
alors qui est parfaitement ici mise en
lumière encore une fois par un appareils
d'électro photo m où vous pouvez voir
ses différents centres énergétiques qui
sont complètement désaxé et puis
rééquilibrer de manière cohérente au
niveau de la colonne vertébrale au
niveau de l' axe central de la personne
générant évidemment à la connexion au
meilleur potentiel énergétique à de
cette personne alors je peux entrer dans
les détails ici parce qu'il ya cette
dimension de centres énergétiques cette
dimension de l'être
retenez simplement que la dimension
physique émotionnel psychique mais aussi
spirituelle cette fameuse spiritualité
enseignée par maman ou effectivement on
apprend avoir confiance en soi en
l'autre en la vie
l'avenir la société également donc cet
alignement est important c'est prise de
conscience de ses différentes dimensions
est importante
alors pour clôturer ici c'est
intervention à ce partage avec vous
trois choses à retenir la première c'est
que chacun d'entre vous est capable en
fait de canaliser littéralement de créer
et de gérer des flux et de générer des
flux énergétiques
comment est bien en posant votre
attention votre conscience et votre
esprit au moment présent
plus vous êtes présent sans que l'esprit
nos partenaires passer dans le futur ou
ne soit parasité par différentes pensé
et bien plus ces flux sont
qualitativement et quantitativement
important est activée et le troisième
point est bien en fonction de la
pratique vous aurez envie d'utiliser la
méditation n'est une il y en a d'autres
la capacité de tourner cette attention
de l'extérieur vers l'intérieur vous
l'avez compris vous vous remplissez
littéralement d'énergie alors
malheureusement maman n'est plus n'est
plus de ce monde a dépassé maintenant de
l'autre côté du voile mais cependant je
vous garanti qu'elle a gagné son combat
de la douleur à l'éveil et de la douleur
à la libération donc rappelez-vous ceci
c'est quand chacun de vous en fait il y
a un pouvoir extrêmement important
infinie un pouvoir et un potentiel
énergétique de bien-être que vous pouvez
utiliser et auquel vous pouvez vous
reconnecter à tout moment et puis encore
pour pour terminer rappelez-vous aussi
l'importance de l'élan du quart ainsi
côté passionné est important
cette énergie du coeur en fête et cinq
mille fois supérieur à ce que le mental
peut générer l'importance de suivre
en fait votre intuition est ce que votre
coeur vous dit merci pour votre présence
[Applaudissements]